Cory Booker and Kamala Harris make total
fools of themselves Twitter bans Alex
Jones permanently and we check the
mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
some days the news cycle is just so much
fun and today is one of those days
because it is full-scale insanity we
will get to all of it but first let's
talk about whether the suit that you're
wearing is any good because the reality
is you probably got it off the rack
somewhere no this is a really nice suit
nope it's hanging on you like a curtain
instead you ought to be going to Indo
Chino and getting yourself a suit that
actually fits you because it's made just
for you Indo Chino is the world's most
exciting made-to-measure menswear
company they make suits and shirts to
your exact measurements for an
unparalleled fit and comfort dudes love
the wide selection of high quality
fabrics and colors to choose from the
option to personalize the details
including lapel lining pockets buttons
writing your own monogram it's really
awesome here's how it works you can
either visit a stylist at one of their
showrooms and have them take your
measurements personally or you can
measure at home and shop online at endo
chino comm then you choose your fabric
inside now choose the customizations
it's really a lot of fun you feel like
James Bond and then it just arrives in
the mail and it's awesome okay so go
check it out right now chinos originated
120 years ago as part of a British
French military uniform designed to be
simple durable comfortable and
camouflage and earthy tones fast forward
to now and this fashion classic has
changed very little until now Indo
chinos are tailored for the perfect fit
and customizable to suit any personal
taste and style this week my listeners
can get any premium Indo Chino suit for
just 359 bucks at ENSO chinos calm and
her promo code Shapiro a checkout that's
50% off the regular price for a
made-to-measure premium suit again Indo
chinos at an introductory price of 79
bucks in the US plus shipping is free
endowed sheknows.com promo code Shapiro
for any premium suit for just three
hundred and fifty nine dollars and free
shipping go check out all of their
awesome product right now Indo Chino
calm again premium Indo Chino suits for
just 359 bucks when you use promo code
Shapiro at checkout alrighty so we are
still in the aftermath of what was a
wild and bizarre Senate Judiciary
Committee hearing over president Trump's
nominee to the Supreme Court to replace
Justice Anthony Kennedy this of course
will be Brett Kavanaugh Brett Kavanaugh
is about as mainstream establishment a
textualist judge as can be he gave no
controversial answers but that did not
stop Democrats from grandstanding
because we now live in a world where
signalling to your base that you are
deeply deeply upset about things is the
way to win political races whether
you're Donald Trump in the 2016
primaries or whether you're Bernie's
in the 2016 primaries the way that you
get your base excited is by showing them
that you are very upset and you are
crusading for truth your crew say it
doesn't matter if you're actually making
up the truth doesn't matter if you're
twisting it doesn't matter if you're
lying it the only thing that really
matters in the end is whether your base
believes that you're passionate about
something because passion has now
outweighed reason as the basic standard
that we should be using in any
particular way well the case in point
over the last couple days has been Cory
Booker when the evolution of Cory Booker
is really something to watch for those
who didn't know anything about Cory
Booker Cory Booker used to be considered
a sort of moderate politician and he was
sort of a third way politician who was
in Newark New Jersey
he was governing across the aisle he was
making friends of schmuely botella he
was a guy who was going to be the new
wave of politics in the country and a
post partisan beyond all of this back
and forth left and right and then you
realize that the best way to elevate
himself inside the Democratic Party was
to act like a loon bag and so he has
decided to go full loony and he did that
during the Senate Judiciary Committee so
you recall a couple of days ago when he
suggested that he was Spartacus which
was real weird it was real weird because
number one he is not in fact Spartacus
number two he doesn't understand the
plot of Spartacus and number three he
didn't actually violate a lot but here
was Cory Booker basically daring people
on the Senate Judiciary Committee to
oust him from the senator for violation
of the rules so the Washington free
beacon did a mash up of Cory Booker
talking about how he had violated the
rules with George Costanza from Seinfeld
talking about how he was the bad man and
it really does fit and in Cory Booker is
a nerd pretending to be the bad guy here
so that he's cool at the base he's gonna
wear a leather jacket and ride a
motorcycle so that the base will love
him and vote for him in 2020
here's cory booker pretending to be
Spartacus I will say that I did
willingly violate the chairs rule on the
committee confidential process I take
full responsibility for violating that
sir and I violated because I sincerely
believe that the public deserves to know
this nominees record in this particular
case his record on issues of race and
the law and I could not understand and I
violated this rule knowingly why why
these issues should be withheld from the
public now I appreciate the comments of
my colleagues this is about the closest
I'll probably ever have in my life to an
I am Spartacus moment
this is making to cleanse there one is
that he violated the Senate rules two or
the documents that he actually released
or somehow damaging to Brett Kavanaugh
not a single thing he said there is true
including that this is an I am Spartacus
moment I've already said this morning on
Twitter I took a Twitter poll as to what
President Trump should call him in the
inevitable tweet right there will be a
tweet from President Trump about Cory
Booker I'm pushing all of my friends at
the White House to get the President to
nickname him far takus I just think that
the alternatives are cryin Cory there's
also drama queen Cory there they're a
few there are a few possibilities but I
think far too kiss is clearly the best
and I'll be very disappointed in the
president if he goes with cry in
somebody else he's already done crying
for I think a couple of other folks he
needs to get more creative with the
insults in any case it turns out none of
this is true so Cory Booker releases
these documents number one he didn't
actually release the documents they were
released earlier that morning so he
didn't violate any a senate rule which
he knew when he said this that's number
one number two the documents that he
released about Brett Kavanaugh are the
things the American public had to see
because we cannot have this veil of
ignorance placed upon our eyes so that
we don't know who will enter it we must
know every it turns out what are those
documents show shows Brett Kavanaugh is
a lawyer who knows things and also
opposed to racial profiling after 9/11
the specific email chain he's talking
about there we need to know what he
thinks about racial profiling
what does Brett Kavanaugh actually say
in those emails he says racial profiling
is probably unconstitutional so we
shouldn't do it so well done Cory Booker
just well done what's hilarious about
this is even even members of left-wing
media who are prepared to praise Cory
Booker who are prepared to treat him as
Spartacus rather than Farkas even those
members of the media had to actually ask
him some tough questions and Cory Booker
had no answer so Anderson Cooper who's
predisposed to sort of like this this
kind of drama he starts asking cory
booker questions and watch as cory
booker's eyes roll up into the back of
his head and he starts murmuring in
tongues it's pretty astonishing
Grassley's office also confirmed you
were told that the restrictions and
documents had been waived before you
spoke today so how do you square that
with the idea that with what you've said
well I square that very easily number
one last night I broke the rules
before they even then they scrambled to
least the document but I continue to
release documents I've released 20 so
far that they have not cleared I am
breaking the rules I'm breaking the Sham
rules 20 documents you check my Twitter
feed anybody in the public now can have
access to the ones that they wanted to
hide if you haven't cleared those yet
maybe they're rushing to catch up to me
and clear those as well and then
Cooper's like yeah but Grassley says
that here he cleared it and so did all
the Democrats on the committee so um
what are you talking about and then
Booker's like whoa but no I'm a bad man
I broke the rules baby look at me look
Eve me my muscle shirt got a pack of
cigarettes rolled up in my t-shirt
sleeve and me I'm a bad boy ladies yeah
sure sure Cory sure so that was solid
stuff and then Kamala Harris it turns
out is also a terrible liar so Kamala
Harris who's better at than Cory Booker
at the site yesterday I compared Cory
Booker - he's like the Nicolas Cage of
politics every scene is just him
snarling at him and making weird faces
well come out Harris is actually pretty
good at this rate she does the stade
routine pretty well there's only one
problem she also doesn't know what she's
talking about so she had an entire
exchange with judge Cavanaugh in which
she accused judge Kavanaugh of talking
about the Millar investigation with
members of President trumps law firm
overcast woods well a couple of facts
that are worthwhile noting number one
Casa de Witts gave disproportionately to
a particularly California Senate
candidate by the name of Kamala Harris
in the last election cycle shouldn't
reveal that number two I do love the
fact that Kamala Harris is is suggesting
that Kevin on knew somebody at Casa wits
and talked about the Muller
investigation without any evidence that
ever happened Casa what's thinking about
the law firm came out they said yeah by
the way no that never happened that's
not that's not a thing that happened I
do actually have footage of Kamala
Harris grilling Cavanaugh from yesterday
yes oh here it is
Kassovitz Benson and Torres which is the
law firm founded by Mark Kassovitz
know who is president Trump's personal
lawyer are you have you had any
conversation about robert muller or his
investigation with anyone at that firm
[Music]
yes or no well is there a person you're
talking to my man you a very direct
question yes or no yeah I I need to know
the
I'm not sure I know everyone who works
at that law firm I don't think you need
to I think you need to know who you
talked with who'd you talk to
okay who'd you talk to and he's like
they're 266 lawyers a casa one sec I
don't know hey I talked to lawyers all
the time I don't know what firm they
work for and that's true I'm sure for
Brett Kavanaugh too who works in legal
circles all the time that's not the
first question you asked somebody you
asked like what kind of law do you
practice where do you practice
it's his dumb question and she has no
evidence of this whatsoever so then Manu
Raju who works for CNN sees Kamala
Harris like walking around the Senate
building yesterday afternoon and here's
what he tweets just ask Kamala Harris
about Kassovitz denial because Kassovitz
came forward and Marc Kassovitz who runs
the firm he says um no one here talked
to Kavanagh about any of this stuff so
this is just made up so a man arrives
your tweets just ask Kamala Harris about
Kassovitz denial then no one at firm
talked to kab now about Muller probe and
she says they're not under oath and so
Rashi said so you don't believe them she
says the question was asked under oath
and he didn't answer okay that so
basically she was lying she had no
evidence whatsoever that Casa Watts had
talked to to Cavanaugh about any of this
stuff she has no evidence that Cavanaugh
has done anything inappropriate with
regard to conversations about the Muller
investigation or anything like that she
just runs around asking questions that
are designed to grandstand for the
public the funniest thing about all of
this is you know who's that you know
who's actually winning the battle among
Democrats for 2020 based on the Senate
Judiciary Committee hearing Michael
avenatti
I'm telling he's my sleeper man he is my
dark horse Michael avenatti the porn
lawyer for stormy Daniels that guy is
now my 2020 front-runner for the
Democrats I am not kidding you think I'm
kidding because it's ridiculous but
guess what everything's ridiculous man
where you been for the last four years
come on Michael avenatti is a better
lawyer than either Corey Booker or
Kamala Harris cory booker by the way ask
something like 56 question 60 questions
during the course of the hearing didn't
ask he didn't mention a case not one
zero cases mentioned in the course of
all of his questions because these
people are not interested in actual
answers a Vinod he started tweeting out
stuff about all of us and he was just
trolling Kamala Harris and Cory Booker
and it was just delicious so avenatti
starts tweeting out about Cory Booker
and Kamala Harris don't know what in the
world they're actually talking about he
tweeted this out two hours ago
I first started trying cases my mentor
taught me two basic things one never
over promise and suggest to the jury
that you have evidence when you don't I
eat get over the tips of your skis and
to never get caught trying to deceive
the jury words to live by in life as
well
hey that is such a sub tweet of both
Kamala Harris and Cory Booker it's
delicious it's delicious so watch as
porn lawyer Michael avenatti runs
circles around the sitting senators from
New Jersey and California I got to tell
you if it's avenatti versus Trump in
2020 I cannot wait man I mean the
entertainment value of that race will be
so unbelievably high and what's going to
be great is that we will actually get
questions and debates like which one of
you had sex with stormy Daniels first
like this will actually be a question in
a debate it'll be unbelievable like we
would if we're gonna go down this path
let's go all the way okay let's let's
just feel the the American people ought
to feel the consequences of the
decisions that they've made politically
for the last several years and I think
what we really deserve well it's not
what the country needs but it's what the
country deserves is in avenatti versus
Trump 2020 race I'm telling you Evan Adi
will crush he's a better debater he's a
better debater than Kamala Harris and
Cory Booker he will crush them on stage
it'll be fantastic and he'll be able to
stand there and say he's these
characters these clowns they could even
do a Senate Judiciary hearing I am going
after the President of the United States
via my brave feminist clients stormy
Daniels famous for her role in the
witches of breast wick yeah ha America's
a great country and we're gonna get to
some more from the Senate Judiciary
hearings because it got even even better
in a couple of ways but first let's talk
about your underwear because come on
we're already talking about presidential
candidates underwear who may as well get
to your underwear as well when it comes
to comfort down below there's underwear
and then there's Tommy John the
revolutionary clothing brand that has
redefined comfort for Americans
everywhere Tommy John obsesses over
every little detail and stitch by using
proprietary fabrics they perform like
nothing you've ever worn before as a
result Tommy John's men's and women's
underwear sport and no wedgie guarantee
which I totally could have used in high
school comfortable stay put waist bands
and a range of fabrics that are
luxuriously soft feather-light moisture
wicking breathable designed to move with
you not against you which means no
bunching no riding up Tommy John is so
confident you gonna love their underwear
that they have a deal it's the best pair
you'll ever wear or
free guarantee if you don't love your
first pair you get a full refund and
that includes their new life changing
women's underwear it sold out in just
six weeks it is now back in stock hurry
over to Tommy John's accom / Shapiro for
20% off your first order that's Tommy
John comm / Shapiro for 20% off best
underwear you're ever gonna wear they
really are fantastic go check them out
right now Tommy John comm / up here oh
and again when you use that / up here
you get 20% off your first order all
right so the the hearings got even
better you remember that earlier this
week there's a woman named zina Bosch
Xena Bosch her father is Jewish her her
father's parents survived the Holocaust
her mother is Mexican but you remember
the Xena Bosch was supposedly a white
supremacist why because she made this
symbol the okay symbol right the okay
symbol is supposedly white power why
because if you take these three fingers
that looks like W and then you take the
circle and then you add a lines in the
bottom and it looks like power okay real
weird stuff but everybody on the Left
decided that this was a secret white
supremacist decoder ring single symbol
and that if you open a cracker jack box
and got precisely the proper ring and
you oriented it correctly then you could
read between the lines of everything
Breck have not ever said so she was
going like this she had hurt her hand on
her on her arm like this and they
suggested that she was giving the white
power symbol and everybody was like what
are you even talking about are you
insane
well three cheers for Xena Bosch Xena
Bosch not all heroes wear capes
yesterday in the hearing
Xena Bosch is sitting behind Brett
Kavanaugh again and just to screw with
people's heads she just takes her hand
she gives the in she gives the same
there it is it's just spectacular just
for the fun of it
just raises her hand she goes like that
and then she can puts it back down and
she knows everybody's gonna go nuts you
know they're a bunch of people on the
right who are sort of prim and proper oh
why would she do that she's giving
credibility left no she's making fun of
them and they deserve it because they're
crazy and this is why whenever folks on
the left leg well Trump is a three-ring
circus
no no American politics is a three-ring
circus President Trump is the ringmaster
he's in that center ring but the other
two rings are filled with Democrats and
Democrat protesters because everyone's
crazy everyone has lost their minds and
so if you can't enjoy the circus well
then get out of the big time
if you can't enjoy the freakshow why are
you here okay we at least should be able
to enjoy the humor of the era in which
we live especially because you know what
things are going pretty well the
unemployment rate is down to three point
nine percent that's like a historic low
it's the best employee unemployment rate
since I think in 2000 and before that
since 1953 people are reentering the
workforce things are so good that you
can view politics right now through one
of two lenses its crisis and we're all
going to die or man this is some funny
bleep I mean this is come on it's really
really funny stuff and the funny stuff
did not in fact end at the Senate
Judiciary Committee President Trump did
a rally last night and president Trump's
rallies are basically stand-up comedy
routines he basically just goes out in
front of a crowd and he reacts to the
crowd and he says a bunch of stuff and
as I have been saying anybody who's
listening to this show for the last two
and a half three years knows that there
is a two-track presidency for President
Trump a true track campaign for
president from president Trump says a
lot of stuff and then a lot of policy
gets implemented and the two things have
nothing to do with one another
because President Trump he's a guy with
a face and stuff comes out of that face
and sometimes the good stuff and
sometimes it's bad stuff but none of
that stuff has anything to do with the
policy because when it comes to
implementing most of the people around
him make the policy Trump reads like the
first sentence of the of the of the
actual policy and then he signs it just
like you just like you sign the form so
you go to the trampoline park with your
kids without actually reading the
details that say you sold your first
child into slavery right just like you
do that that's how President Trump signs
executive order so you know the
President of the United States when he
does these rallies this is really what
he enjoys so if you and you have to see
the rallies as what they are they're not
policy speeches they don't have any sort
of deep meaning the president doesn't
have the power under our system to be
Mussolini I don't think President Trump
really wants to be Mussolini I think he
just likes the the kind of cheering
throngs of people around him because he
seeks approval but yeah that means that
you have to enjoy what President Trump
does for what it is
which is basically a giant Gallagher
routine where he takes some watermelon
and smashes it onstage and hits the
people in the front row so here's
President Trump yesterday talking about
the failing in New York Times and he
says that they ought to investigate
themselves which is a weird suggestion
since I don't know why they would
they're a private company but sure why
the hell not here's President Trump the
latest
active resistors is the op-ed published
in the failing New York Times by an
anomalous really an anomalous gutless
coward come on this is fun stuff guys I
mean we got to enjoy you got just yeah
yeah revel in the fact that the man
mispronounced the word anonymous twice
in seven seconds and then basically just
said an ominous enemy numinous a guy a
guy I know who it was a guy whatever
with a face if they said stuff a guy I
know I mean ominous you know I mean ah
boo boo but dude it's a solid stuff from
the president right there and then the
president also continued there should be
clip this would be clip six talking
about he tweeted this out he asked if
the New York Times would investigate
itself
he says the investigative journalists of
the New York Times going to investigate
themselves who is the anomalous letter
writer but he spelled it correctly at
that time you know who is the anonymous
letter writer okay so you know what
what's so funny about this whole
controversy over the anonymous op-ed
that hit the pages of the New York Times
a couple of days ago and oh my goodness
the accusations that there are people
who sit around President Trump and they
steer him and they make sure he doesn't
go off the rails and hit their the
steady state the I read that again last
night cuz I I honestly I'm having a
tough time understanding why this is a
big deal or why people didn't know this
of course there are people around the
President of the United States who are
working to thwart his worst instincts
have you ever had a boss who is not a
bad boss they're just kind of crazy have
you ever had a boss like this I'm sure
you have people in my company have that
boss every single day and what you do if
you have a boss like that is you slow
walk things I used to have a boss who's
like this he'd get on the phone with me
and you'd have an idea and his idea was
invariably something completely crazy
you say something what what if we built
a rocket made of cheese and I'd be like
sure
okay I'm sure that's a good idea and
then you get really enthusiastic the
more you push back against him the more
enthusiastic could be about this rocket
made of cheese you'd be like no that's
you know I'm not sure how that's going
to survive the orbital entry I don't
really understand how the cheese is
going to survive the orbital entry
put aside the actual logistics and cost
of building a rocket made of cheese or
why you'd want to do that but I don't
know how no you know what that's
something we can figure out and
something we can figure out we couldn't
we can figure that one out the important
thing is that there be a rocket made of
cheese and them and you realize the more
I push back against this idea the more
enthusiastic this person's gonna get
about the idea so instead of pushing
back what you start to his good note
you know what boss it's a great idea I I
don't care whether talkin Swiss I don't
care what talk in Munster I don't care
if we're talking Monterey Jack great
idea you know what let's think about
that one let me think on let me mo on
that one and then you just do nothing
and then like a year later the guy says
whatever happened to that rocket made it
she say you know we checked it out we
thought about the cost you remember we
had a conversation about is it really
work he's like oh yeah I do remember
that that's how you slow walk with your
boss if you think people around the
White House don't do it with their boss
you're out of your mind and it's not a
constitutional coup it's not look if
Trump wants to fire these people who can
fire these people they all work for him
a coup is when they actively chained him
in the basement and prevent him from
doing things he has not a thing but
again it's imperative that we all go
crazy and speaking of everybody going
crazy over at the pages of the New York
Times Paul Krugman I don't know what
he's on I don't know what sort of coke
he is smoking oh you don't smoke coke to
you unless it's crack I don't know
anything about coke I don't know I don't
know he's snorting Paul Krugman suggests
that crisis is imminent
why because Brett Kavanaugh is going to
kill the Constitution so he moved away
from voting Republican is gonna kill
democracy and now he's on Brett
Kavanaugh is going to kill the
Constitution which is weird because it's
a document and you can't kill it because
the document will talk about Paul
Krugman who has joined the the ranks of
the crazy in just one second but first
let's talk about your ability to
preserve your memories okay so this may
not be the world's easiest time in
politics but I'm sure that you're having
fun with your family you got pictures
and old tapes and you got all sorts of
old memories with your family and you
want to take that stuff and preserve it
you don't want boxes stuff piled up in
your garage instead what you ought to do
is take all that stuff ship it over to
the folks at legacy box they send it
back to you in the form of a thumb drive
or a playable CD DVD and then you got
everything at fingers touch right I mean
you can do all of this it's very very
easy and preserving it for future
generations that what legacy box does
for you you load legacy box
your old tapes film pictures audio
recordings you send it back you get them
back in a couple of weeks on DVD or a
convenient thumb drive ready to watch
her and relive it it's perfectly safe
they send you a bunch of stickers with
actual barcodes on them so you can track
every piece of content that you send
them legacy box takes care of everything
they provide updates at every step of
the process I've used legacy box it is
fantastic again I think there's very
little in life more important than
preserving memories that you're gonna
forget about and they're just gonna mold
her in the garage go check it out right
now for a limited time go to legacy box
comm slash men enter my promo code Ben
got a 40% discount on your order that's
legacy box comm slash Ben again legacy
box comm slash Ben go check it out right
now and you get that spectacular 40
percent discount on your order okay so
as I say Brett Brett Kavanaugh
apparently is going to end the
Constitution this coming from Paul
Krugman a guy who thinks that the
Constitution is basically a defunct
document we shouldn't be paying
attention to anyway but the levels of
panic that are evident in a time where
there really ought not be panic again
things are pretty good things are pretty
good it's just the feeling of chaos that
I think is making everybody a little bit
nuts and the President does contribute
to that there's no question about it and
I said a few shows ago that I get the
same feeling about the president that I
have about my two and a half year old
son and this happens a lot it might
might we have heard some wonderful kid
just lovely just a really nice kid lots
of fun by the time I hit 7:30 and I'm
like you need to go to bed now you need
to go to bed I'm tired my forget about
you being tired I'm tired okay I need
you been running around trying to kill
yourself all day I've been stopping you
from killing yourself all day now I need
you to go to sleep I feel like the
American public are sort of like that
about politics now it's like both
parties are trying constantly to stick
their fingers and light sockets and
we're constant that guys don't do it
just don't just don't do it and like no
I want to I want to stick my finger in
the light socket no don't do it just
stop it just go to bed come on just good
but it's bedtime daddy needs a daddy
needs a drink go to bed okay that's how
the American people feel about politics
right now
but both parties seem insistent and
everybody on all sides he was insistent
on sticking their finger in the light
socket so Paul Krugman has stuck his
finger in the light socket his hair is
now sticking straight up he has a piece
in the New York Times called Kavanagh
will kill the Constitution how will he
do this how will he achieve the murder
of an inanimate object well let me tell
you at a fundamental level the attempt
Jim Brett Kavanaugh on to the Supreme
Court closely resembles the Republicans
passed a tax cut last year you mean like
with a majority vote of the Senate like
that he says true Cavanaugh is getting a
hearing which the tax bill never did but
he's bobbing and weaving his way through
refusing to answer even straightforward
questions displaying an evasive Necedah
Lee at odds with the probity we used to
expect in Supreme Court justices this is
fully delusional crap the Ginsberg rule
which was named after Ruth Bader
Ginsburg is that judges who are being
asked questions about current cases
future cases past cases should not give
answers so this is just Paul Krugman
being an ignoramus
he says if Cavanaugh has confirmed we'll
be trying to navigate a turbulent era in
American politics with the Supreme Court
in which two seats were effectively
stolen stolen you can't steal the seat
again we're killing documents and
stealing seats all the teachers still
there this first Republicans refused to
even give President Barack Obama's
nominee a hearing then they filled two
positions with nominees chosen by a
president who lost the popular vote and
eked out an electoral college win only
with aid from a hostile foreign power ah
so that's what we're going that Trump is
not legitimate because Russia helped him
out I mean it's amazing how far the
Democrats will go in order to claim that
Trump's victory is illegitimate you can
hate Trump as much as you want his
victory is legitimate that's the way the
system works
he didn't win because of Russian
election interference that's not why he
won the election he won the election
because nobody voted for Hillary Clinton
and you adults decided to nominate the
least likable human being in the history
of planet Earth a woman with the
charisma of a speed bump and all of the
joy of a dying squirrel a woman who
couldn't even be bothered to get on a
plane to Wisconsin because she was too
busy hanging out with Lena Dunham that
potato of a human like this is this is
but no it's all about the Russians what
a Justice Kavanagh conduct himself with
the caution appropriate to such a
fraught situation well miracles of
personal redemption do happen writes
Paul Krugman but it's very unlikely
you're right judge Kavanagh is when I
think of a risk-taker I think of a Brett
Kavanaugh a Catholic who coaches his
girls basketball team and has spent 20
years being one of the preeminent
lawyers in Washington DC I think of that
guy and I think yeah as a risk-taker
right there
there's a guy who's going to conduct
himself as a radical in every possible
way this is after all what do we know
about Kavanagh there's a lot we don't
thanks to the unprecedented way
Republicans in the Trump administration
are stonewalling on thousands of pages
of his record he's turned over more
documents than any candidate in the
history of the Supreme Court he's known
for hundreds of thousands of pages of
documents the Democrats don't care about
at all
but Krugman finishes let me make a last
minute appeal to Republican senators who
care about America's future if there any
left don't do this
a vote for Kavanagh will be a vote to
destroy the legitimacy of one of the
last federal institutions standing the
the level of panic is just astonishing
and then early winter Mariinsky who's a
First Amendment attorney and now I guess
he's Dean of is a USC law school where
he is now yeah yeah I guess it's over at
Berkley law school i he used to be at
USC he has a piece today called why why
Cavanaugh likened the Supreme Court
justices to umpires that's nonsense and
he knows it and then he suggested
justices are not umpires at all
umpires apply rules and have little
leeway in determining how those rules
should be interpreted the Supreme Court
creates the rules and justices have an
enormous discretion in how to interpret
the law by likening himself to an umpire
Cavanaugh was contending his views don't
matter at all that is false
so just say square these two editorials
you have Paul Krugman claiming that
Cavanaugh is a radical who's going to
use the Constitution as a baton and you
Vernon winter Mariinsky insisting that
the Constitution is a living document
that can be twisted any which way by
anybody who's on the court so which is
it is Cavanaugh going to kill the vital
Constitution or is Cavanaugh going to
enliven it and twist it in a variety of
different ways the left can't decide and
so they just continue to whine and
complain about a done deal okay this is
already a done deal we all know that
it's a done deal but that's not going to
stop democrats from complaining
incessantly speaking of democrats
complaining incessantly twitter has now
permanently banned
Alex Jones that was only a matter of
time I've suggested that as much as I
dislike Alex Jones and I know I know
there are a lot of people you know much
email I get from folks who think that
Alex Jones is on the level I don't think
that Alex Jones is actually some sort of
genius who has decoded the
conspiratorial nature of American life
between selling mail supplements ads and
that in any case Alex Jones now it's
John's okay he's been banned now by
Twitter according to CNBC the ban
appears to be related to a heated
exchange between Joe
and a CNN reporter Wednesday which
Shone's live streamed on the Twitter own
video service periscope Jones ranted at
the reporter as well as Twitter CEO Jack
Dorsey following back-to-back
congressional hearings where Dorsey
addressed online election meddling as
well as accusations of political bias
and conservative censorship on the
platform so Twitter finally banned him
they said we took this action based on
new reports of tweets and videos posted
yesterday that violate our abusive
behavior policy in addition to the
accounts past violations there are only
a couple of serious problems with this
one is that Hamas is still on there the
others that louis farrakhan is still on
there one of the big problems with all
these social media companies that are
now banning people is that they still
have not set an actual standard for what
counts as something that is worthwhile
banning they still have not clarified
any of this stuff and that continues to
be a serious problem for social media
companies there's a reason that the left
is is wildly mistrusted by the right
when it comes to how they are running
these social media companies okay after
this I'm going to discuss with you just
a delicious story about a new socialist
face for the Democrats who it turns out
is just a crazy person but they're still
pumping anyway but first let's talk a
little bit about your investment
okay betterment is the best way to
manage your money outsmart average the
investing tool for people who refuse to
settle for average investing betterment
gives you technology design to help you
make more from your investments
unlimited expert advice designs help you
make smart financial decisions I have an
investment advisor you ought to have one
too but it shouldn't cost you what it
cost me to have an investment advisor
that's why you need betterment tax
efficient investing strategies that
gives you an edge low transparent fees
constant access to information and tools
allowing you to track progress toward
your goals you should be doing financial
planning you should have somebody
helping you manage your money well that
is what betterment is for again they
help you outsmart average sign up today
and get up to one year managed for free
betterment
I'm telling you investment involves risk
but Ben Shapiro listeners can get up to
one year manage for free for more
information visit betterment comm slash
Shapiro that's betterment comm slash
appear they will help you ensure that
you have all the up-to-date information
on your own finances they will give you
all the advice that you need to help you
make smart financial decisions for
yourself and it means that you're not
consuming an ordinate amount of time
thinking about this stuff that's really
what they're great for betterment comm
slash reparo again betterment comm slash
capiro go check them out
check them out right now okay so if you
want to see the rest of the show we're
gonna get into the mailbag go over to
daily wire comet right now $9.99 a month
gets you a subscription to daily where
you get the rest of this show live the
rest Manitou Clavin the show live the
rest of michael Knowles's show live if
that's something that you're into and
also if you get the annual subscription
you get this the leftist here is hot or
cold tumbler filling every day with the
tears of Cory Booker I can't say they
taste the best but they are plentiful so
go check it out right now for $99 a year
pretty spectacular deal also go
subscribe over at youtube or itunes when
you do then you get access to our Sunday
special this week it is christina hoff
sommers we have some great ones coming
up in the near future as well go check
us out we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so I have to tell you this spectacular
story about a democratic socialist
candidate who is being pumped heavily by
the left her name is Julia Salazar she's
a wild left candidate she calls herself
a Democratic Socialist just like
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez she's running
for New York's 18th state Senate
District as part of Brooklyn containing
neighborhoods ranging from Williamsburg
to Cypress Hills she's receiving a lot
of attention because she's part of this
new wave of Democratic socialists and
all the rest it's just amazing well it
turns out there's only one problem
apparently she's a pathological liar so
a couple of things she claims that she's
Jewish she claims she's an immigrant she
claims she was working-class none of
those three things are true according to
members of her own family
she has no Jewish background what makes
her have a Jewish background supposedly
her dad once said that maybe he comes
from a morano family her brother says I
don't know what the heck she's talking
about she's basically making this up so
that she can claim she's Jewish which
makes an excuse for her being wildly
anti-israel anti-israel Jews like to
talk about their level of Judaism or or
their Jewish ethnicity specifically
because they don't care about Judaism
and it gives them cover to be as anti
Zionist and anti-israel as they want to
be Jews who actually care about Judaism
are never anti Israel I mean this is
just a rule of thumb okay there's not a
single Jew who seriously cares about
Judaism who is anti-israel if there are
you're talking about like
extraordinarily fringe folks you're
talking about like natori cartel which
has eight members and you always see
them being photographed by the New York
Times as though they're representatives
of some sort of major has sect it's like
nine guys but in any case the Julia
Salazar claim she's Jewish she's not she
claims she's working class or grew up
working-class she's not her parents were
upper-middle class she claims that she
was brought to the United States as an
immigrant that's not true she's an
American citizen and she was born an
American citizen she claims that she
that her parents were that she's
basically an illegal immigrant that's
not true either that doesn't stop voxcom
the repository for all stupidity on the
internet from writing a piece called
Julia Salazar the socialist politician
accused of lying about her past
explained and then they claim that it's
basically a he-said she-said situation
the only problem being that she is a
liar and the people who are actually
making the opposite claims have no
interest in lying because they're
members of her own family since he
basically makes all this stuff up
Democrats continue to push her anyway I
love this
giulio was starting at Columbia
University and figured New York would be
a good place to get in touch with her
possibly Jewish roots uh-huh she got
involved with pro-israel activism akashi
would later announce mm-hmm and became a
frequent presence at Hillel the main hub
for campus Jewish life by early 2010 she
said I was even going to services with
friends except for the fact that this is
not correct
okay when she was 21 she had the
politics and religious beliefs of a
conservative Christian in a series of
tweets preserved by hen Mazique Salazar
quote - pastored Apostles Church in New
York so she's a really bad Jew okay so
this is so not only that the tablet
tablet has done a bunch of reporting on
this and they point to a mysterious
shift and sells herself conception at
occurring in 2013 a few months after a
trip to Israel by September of 2013 she
said she kept kosher at her apartment
she says that she formally converted to
Judaism
except that she doesn't remember when
she said she took a B'nai Mitzvah course
that if completed would amount to a
conversion which of course hasn't that's
insane
okay just as somebody who knows a little
bit about the Judaism you don't go to a
bat mitzvah course and become a Jew
that's not the way this works it's
actually a long arduous process to
become Jewish choose they actually
discourage conversions I know Alex in
the back room is like oh no dude don't
worry I mean we're keeping you out of a
pretty exclusive club of getting
murdered on a regular basis for several
thousand years that's that's
legitimately like our interest in
discouraging convert slike you really
sure you want to be part of this club
you really sure you want to be part of
this club it ain't that great but if she
is she claims that she's Jewish anyway
she doesn't meet any standard for Jewish
identity she is she's not Jewish it's
just it's amazing stuff but the left is
closed it gets even better than that
there's an article in the tablet
suggesting the choose arrested in 2011
on suspicion of criminal use of personal
information police reports describe
Julia Salazar attempting to impersonate
CAI Hernandez a family friend and then
wife of baseball star Keith Hernandez so
now we actually get an immense baseball
to explain Julia Salazar apparently kaya
Hernandez said she recognized Salazar as
a voice on the phone and subsequently
filed a police report because what
happened is that she was attempting to
access the bank account of CAI Hernandez
a family friend and then wife of
baseball star Keith Hernandez the
incident is chronicled in police reports
court records in
Oh files all of what you've been
obtained by tablet i learning all this
about her actually I think she's a
pretty good candidate for Congress I
can't I can't
yeah I honestly I've got I got nothing i
got nothing so alrighty let's do some
mailbag here because this week has been
too ridiculous Justin asked hey Ben I
just recently started a job as a sales
person a call center my dilemma is that
it pays very well for the experience I
currently have and when I met in college
however I do feel my supervisors want me
to be as deceptive and dishonest just
enough in order to legally get by in
order to sell as much as possible
I don't exactly feel comfortable with
this although I can't find another job
that pays even close to it any
recommendations on what I should do yeah
don't push stuff that you you don't
believe in no I mean we have a lot of
people who want to advertise on the
program we only have advertisers on the
program that I've personally tried or
that people on my staff have personally
tried because I'm not gonna advertise
products that I think are BS we've
turned down products before we'll turn
down products in the future if you feel
immoral doing what you're doing no
amount of money is going to make you
feel any better about that so I would
suggest that you take a lower paying job
take a couple of jobs your your your
ethics are worth a little more than that
rachel says hi Ben
what do you think of the new Aquaman
movie coming out this winter well the
trailer looks just awful first of all I
think DC totally screwed up the release
of these movies they should have done
exactly what Marvel did they introduced
every character individually and then
they had the crossover instead DC
basically took the crossover from the
very beginning right they did Justice
League from the very very beginning they
did Batman vs Superman from the very
beginning Batman vs Superman by the way
still an underrated movie I know I know
you hate me for saying that it is the
original Batman vs Superman is he is it
is not a bad movie it's a lot better
than a lot of Marvel movies yes I know
stop yelling at me okay I know but it is
true the Aquaman movie looks just
terrible it looks cgi centered and I
don't know how you mate how you mess it
honestly the Aquaman story is pretty
good but they're gonna find a way to
screw it up DC needs to scrap the whole
the whole thing and just start over from
the beginning instead they have they
have failed pretty dramatically to do
that hey Daniel says hey Ben I was
talking with a colleague who's a lawyer
about constitutional interpretation at
one point he said he does not know the
correct way to interpret the
Constitution because it doesn't say how
to interpret it as an originalist how'd
you respond to this thanks shabbat
shalom and have a blessed year well the
the correct way to answer this question
is are you
an idiot really because when you
interpret anyone well you should say to
him is I'm saying words to you right now
how do you interpret those words how do
you interpret the words that I am saying
to you right now like right here when I
asked you that question how do you
interpret it how do you know what I'm
saying and presumably they'll say well
you're using words and we talk with each
other and I know what you're saying
because I know what words mean that's
how you interpret law it really is not
that difficult and when you're talking
about the interpretation of old text
then you have to determine what they
meant at the time they were said because
if I were to let's say that I were to
honor to the sentence I want an apple
and a hundred years in the future now I
write that sentence down and 100 years
in the future for some odd reason we
have decided to call cows apples yeah
and no one knows why that's just what
happened and now 100 years from now
you're reading that sentence to
determine the actual meaning of the
sentence I want an apple would you just
look to common meaning at the time that
it was written or would you say what he
really meant was cow because the word
Apple evolves over time
that's not the way verbiage works
whenever we talk with each other we are
talking about the definitions at the
time it's true for every conversation
it's true for every law and it's true
for constitutional interpretation as
well Samuel says hey Ben should
naturally-occurring monopolies be
allowed to exist in a free market or
should they be or should they be
disbanded for hindering the progress of
the market Thanks they should be allowed
to exist in a free market I am pretty
antitrust and I'm pretty anti antitrust
law
I think antitrust law is used far too
often for companies that don't actually
have a monopoly a natural monopoly is a
monopoly that is not enforced by law
it's not it's a it's a monopoly in which
the government is not cramming down
particular rules that favor one company
like you know the Royal Dutch shipping
company or something it's not that it's
where you have a company that's just so
good at what it does that it's creative
monopoly in the market monopolies
natural monopolies do not tend to last
very long because usually there are
competitors that find something new or
there's a whole new branch of sort of
invention that makes this particular
company obsolete this idea that somebody
has a monopoly now that means they'll
have a monopoly in a hundred years
that's just not the way things work and
it never has been the way things work
when you have a free market economy
Diana says what did the daily wear crew
put in your calf FC this past week you
sir are lit well you know III think it
has less to do with what was in the cuff
a fee I think it has more
the coffe Fe infusing all aspects of
American politics clearly everybody has
been grinding up the coffe Fe and
snorting it in lines because that's big
Cory Booker was litt Donald Trump was
litt Kamala Harris was lit things were
lit man I mean it was just a lit week
John says hi Ben my college roommate was
born and raised in China but has become
more libertarian as you lived here he
wanted to ask if communism is the result
of actual needs of a working class or
simply a result of wanton greed I know
marx and engels were middle or upper
class intellectuals but did they have
any connection with poorer people has
communism actually ever been effectively
used in the Utopia describe where
everyone's needs are met and everyone is
truly equal any response is greatly
appreciated thanks very much your show
is awesome
well there's there's an ongoing
controversy over whether Marxism the
terminology of Marxism applies to areas
of Western civilization in which the
basis for an economy is actually
capitalist so the most modern examples
being used now our places like Denmark
or Sweden or the Nordic countries the
left used to admire the USSR and Cuba in
Venezuela and then it turns out all
those places are absolute crap holes so
now they've decided that instead it
applies to all these Nordic countries
that are really capitalist with a bunch
of redistributionist superstructure
placed on top now I don't think that's
what Marxism described you to read the
Communist Manifesto it talks about full
nationalization of resources it talks
about the workers actually taking over
all of the companies and that's not
what's happening in the vast majority of
these Nordic countries even in places
with high rates of nationalization
places like Norway those companies are
run in state-sponsored capitalist
fashion I don't think that's sustainable
and I think that absent Norway's awesome
oil wealth
they'll be experiencing significant
financial difficulties right now at the
moment because that's exactly what
happened to Sweden from basically 1970
to the mid 1990s or mid 2000s rather so
no I do not think that Marxism works as
an economic system I think the the draw
of Marxism the idea of from each
according to his ability to each
according to his need is is a draw
toward it spends lose it depends who's
articulating it if it's somebody who's
at the upper end of the economic
spectrum then it's somebody who wants to
consider themselves charitable without
actually giving charity and if it's
somebody at the bottom of the economic
spectrum then very often it's coming
from a place of I want what that other
guy has I think Marxism is built on a
bunch of lies about the human condition
about human nature and Marxism makes
promises
about the transformation of human beings
into better human beings if we just
change the free-market system in which
we live we just inhibited the freedom of
everybody then we'd all become better
human beings I think all of it is
nonsense I think all of it is immoral as
far as whether it works the answer is it
depends on what the goal was if the goal
was to level all human beings then sure
it levels all human beings in Venezuela
in poverty except for the ruling class
if the goal is to transform human nature
giant fail if the goal is a prosperous
society giant fail capitalism creates
prosperity redistribution isms just
passes that stuff around and inhibits
prosperity Alec says too he who is
rumored to be the husband of the hottest
doctor indeed how do you actually find a
partner who is also dating for marriage
it seems to be difficult in college so
here is the answer ask a woman ok most
women are actually interested in dating
for marriage most women think that men
are not interested in dating for
marriage this is it this is I really
think that the vast majority of women
who say that they're interested in
dating for fun it's because they've many
of them have been told by the feminist
movement that their lives will be richer
if they did for fun don't lock yourself
down they basically they've been given
the same slogan that men were given back
in the 1960s and 70s go your Wild Oats
be free do what you want I don't think
that deep down that's what most women
actually want I don't think it's hard to
find a woman who wants commitment I
think most women actually want
commitment out of men in fact I think
it's the single thing that women want
most out of men is a level of commitment
and a level of stability so ask like
really ask so ask a woman on a date and
then on the first date say you know what
I want to tell you I take dating really
seriously and when I date I'm really
dating with marriage in mind and if that
scares you that's ok we don't have to do
this but you know I take this stuff
seriously and I want to have a good time
obviously while we're dating but having
a good time is not actually the chief
purpose of this if I wanted to have a
good time I go golfing right but you
know if you want to if you want to do
something meaningful here let's talk
about first of all the other answer the
other answer is go to a church now you
want to find somebody who wants to date
for marriage go to a church go to a
synagogue go someplace where people take
commitment seriously and you'll find a
bevy of people who are interested in
dating for marriage look it's the norm
in the Orthodox community in the
Orthodox community there's no such thing
as dating for fun because you can't have
any fun
until you're married anyway so goji is
so dating for dating for marriage is the
norm it used to be the norm in the
religious community and again I think
that a lot of women might find this
mildly refreshing if not majorly
refreshing and if they don't find a
refreshing she's not somebody want to
marry anyway John says hi Thanos indeed
what one modern political thinker today
deserves far more serious attention than
they currently receive and why well I
think Thomas soul is the best political
thinker on the scene people who asked me
before if I could appoint an ideal
president who would it be and I've
always said Thomas so I think he is
terrific I think of people who are of
younger age matthew cottan Eddie does a
lot of great writing I think that David
French over at National Review does a
lot of really interesting writing or in
Cass who's over at I believe he's at
which Institute is yet Manhattan thank
you he does a lot of really interesting
writing there they're a bunch of folks
Jonathan hight does a lot of interesting
writing I recommend a lot of these folks
his books on the program before and I
think that you know we'll have to put up
we've been promising for a while that we
put up a reading list on the website
we'll actually have to do that with all
of the recommendations because it's
legitimately hundreds of books at this
point hi Travis hi Ben you and the rest
of the four horsemen Clavin Olson Walsh
keep me going through the workweek with
all the chaos going on with the Senate
hearing on Cavanaugh what are your
thoughts on the movement in some circles
of the conservative movement to repeal
the 17th amendment do you think it would
fix a lot of the grandstanding we see
now because the Senators would be
representing the state and not their
constituents keep up the great work so
listen I think that the the idea of
popularly elected senators is really
idiotic I think the goal of the Senate
was it's disproportionate in terms of
representation specifically because the
states are supposed to be represented
not just the people of the states the
house was so now you have the house
basically representing the same
constituency as the Senate which defeats
the purpose of having a Senate in the
first place I don't think that that
there's a reason why senators should be
voted by the same people who vote the
members of the House of Representatives
would it solve all of our problems of
course it wouldn't solve all of our
problems because you have pandering
state politicians who want to spend a
lot of money to but would it be better
than the current system yeah I think so
populism is a result in some places of
not having checks and balances in the
nature of the constituencies for
particular politicians brana's has - I
loved last week Sunday special with Edie
feasor
and your discussion about the
philosophical and logical arguments for
God's existence I've purchased his book
and looked forward to reading it I was
wondering if he had any recommendations
for good books in a similar vein from
the Atheist point of view to provide
some balance to my reading man there are
a couple of books that come to mind
immediately they're actually not by
Richard Dawkins or Sam Harris there's
there's one book I wish I could remember
the name of this book it's basically
trying to debunk every argument for
God's existence and they go through the
ontological ontological argument and
various other arguments that have been
traditionally used I remember reading it
and and finding it interesting but not
convincing I'll honestly I'll have to
get back to you on that one but I do
have like a shelf full of atheist books
that make exactly these arguments over
and over again and there are some pretty
well written ones that I remember this
one was not in circulation a lot I'll
really have to look it up and I'm sorry
I don't have it at my tongue all right
let's see final final one Stephen says
if you could get in a time machine and
clerk for any US Supreme Court justice
who would you pick I would I would go
clerk for Chief Justice John Marshall
and I'd reverse Marbury vs. Madison I'd
sneak in a reversal of Marbury vs.
Madison and also then I would I would
work to reverse McCulloch versus
Maryland they're a couple of bad early
decided cases or if you're gonna do that
if you're gonna if you're gonna be like
the the resistance inside the Supreme
Court then I suppose that you would go
back and and clerk for Justice tani and
then somehow prevents him from writing
Dred Scott right you'd start there okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things I like
President Trump couldn't help himself
this week you knew it was coming today
he finally decided to tweet out about
Nike which is exactly what Nike wanted
right Nike wanted this tweet so he
tweeted out what was Nike thinking what
they were thinking pretty much that you
would tweet out about it I mean that
that's really what Mikey was thinking
when they decided to feature Colin
Kaepernick a loser backup quarterback
for the San Francisco 49ers he's not
worked in a couple of years but who note
for the national anthem thereby making
him a national hero worth millions of
dollars and they were thinking that you
would tweet about it and then everybody
who hates Trump would go out and buy
Nike sneakers thereby demonstrating once
again that capitalism always wins but it
is it is worth noting here that Nikes
ratings have indeed it have indeed
plummeted they've been hit with with
sort of really bad poll numbers there is
a report
from morning console they suffered a
34-point drop in favorability overall
including dips in nearly every single
demographic since announcing the
Kapernick ad campaign their favorability
dropped to they were in 69% a plus 69
percent favorable impression it is now
declined 34 points to plus 35 favorable
among younger generations Nike users
african-americans and other key
demographics Nikes favorability declined
rather than improved before the
announcement 49 percent of Americans
said they were absolutely certain or
very likely to buy a Nike products that
figure is down to 39 percent for now so
that is it that's a pretty astonishing
drop and again good evidence that when
you alienate a large portion of the
American population it's a bad idea
but all of that was dependent on the
president not getting involved now he's
gotten involved which means that a bunch
of people are gonna rally to Nikes
support again I want to correct
something I said yesterday so yesterday
I said that kneeling for the national
anthem it you didn't want to have a
conversation I think that was true for
Kaepernick I don't think Kaepernick
wanted to have a conversation he would
not hold the conversation I think
Kaepernick is the worst example of this
group of folks I think there were some
members of the NFL who knelt usually in
the aftermath of the Kaepernick stuff
who then went and held meetings with
various legislators and tried to have
conversations I would ask that if Nike
wanted to feature somebody who's trying
to make a positive difference
why not feature those people and the
answer is because it's all virtue
signaling so I just wanted to correct
that impression there are some people
who I know who I think probably want to
have good conversations but it's not
Colin Kaepernick okay other things that
I like
so Jeffery Owens was an actor on The
Cosby Show and you would recognize his
face if he saw it he was essentially
shamed because there was a story in some
of the tabloids and then picked up by
some major media outlets that showed
that he was working as a cashier at a
New Jersey Trader Joe's it appeared in
the Daily Mail and the the stupidity of
featuring this as though there's some
sort of shame to working in a Trader
Joe's in order to make ends meet because
he used to be a famous actor it's just
it's just gross obviously it's just a
gross thing but the impact of this story
is that now the guys got a job again so
he's about to have a 10-episode arc on
his hilar Perry show he's about to start
getting acting jobs again so I'm glad to
see that people resonated to Jeffrey
Owens his support everybody basically
came out and said this is absurd anybody
who is working a job ought to be praised
for working that job there's no shame to
working at a Trader Joe's just because
you used to be a famous actor
now the other night I took my daughter
to a concert at the Hollywood Bowl with
John Williams conducting and it was
really a lot of fun and they showed a
clip from et with the with the orchestra
playing in the background and the the
best thing any tease the older brother I
can't remember the name of the guy who
plays the older brother in et he's
really terrific he never did another
acting job again those his last acting
job he decided not to do it last check I
think he was working as a mailman he has
like a nice family somewhere out in the
boonies and he works as a mailman is
there anything wrong with that I think
not I think there's something really
nice about that I think the idea that
acting is is only worthwhile if you
never have to work at Trader Joe's and
we have to shame people for working at
Trader Joe's is gross good for Hollywood
for making room for Jeffrey Owens again
on the basis of all of this so that's a
thing that I like today okay time for a
quick thing that I hate and then we'll
get out of here for the weekend
so today's thing I hate this is
California which is just this is why if
you're a leftist you really should
believe in federalism because federalism
allows you to try out the dumbest ideas
possible and California is the place
where we do all of this according to NBC
News California on August 30th voted to
force publicly traded companies based in
California to have at least one woman on
their board by 2019 and depending on the
size of the company one two three women
by 2021 California Senate bill 826 is
sponsored by California State Senator
Hanna Beth Jackson Democrat now heads to
Governor Jerry Brown's desk if it
becomes law this will be the first
example of a state mandated gender quota
of its kind in the u.s. it's just
idiotic in every possible way first of
all you're gonna have the government
actually setting up quotas this seems to
me fully unconstitutional it's violation
of the Equal Protection Clause the the
notion that you are going to force with
that you are going to force companies to
hire somebody specifically on the basis
of gender is insane because if you did
this in Reverse you said hey there's an
all-female company we need at least one
male on that board people would say what
are you talking about or it's an all
it's it's a black company right so
company has an all black boy so you know
what we need a white person on that
board or what why not have a
transgendered person I think you can
fulfill all of the quotas at once there
you have a black transgender person
you'd have Rachel Dolezal on that board
and everything will be great
you fulfilled all of the various quotas
all at once what does this have to do
with making business better the answer
is nothing because here's the reality if
I have a publicly traded company and I
have five members of the board and they
tell me I need to bring a woman onto the
board you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna bring on a woman who's you think
gonna bolt like everybody else on the
board or I'm gonna go out number the
woman with a bunch of other people who
agree with me this doesn't actually have
any impact on how the company is run in
other words they're already laws that
prevent gender discrimination in hiring
and firing the the notion that you have
to go out of your way to stack the
boards with particular affirmative
action candidates is really bad for
business and not only that it probably
it probably encourages companies not to
go public in the first place or to
relocate out of state I mean listen we
have a we have a board in our company
and we're not a publicly traded company
we're a private company if ever we
decided to go public if this is the wall
in the state of California we will
agility move the company out of state or
at least we'd seriously consider it
because the more restrictions you put on
publicly traded companies in your state
the more they're gonna look other places
we don't have to be located here we can
move very easily so California once
again virtue signaling instead of
thinking about all of this stuff in a
serious fashion and again the number of
women who are on corporate boards is
already increasing because there are
lots of qualified women to be on boards
it's it's just it's the height of
stupidity but again California is a
place that elected Kamala Harris senator
so what can you say for us out here all
righty
well we will be back here next week now
remember I'm not gonna be back in there
Monday or Tuesday because it is Rosh
Hashanah so I'm gonna be celebrating my
New Year and enjoying my time off but I
will be back on Wednesday which means I
am sure that all things will happen
Monday and Tuesday and I'll have a lot
to talk about I will see you then I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018